I've been invited to speak at a virtual
event and working on the PowerPoint
presentation I'm practicing I don't have
a lot of experience giving presentations
uh curious if you have any advice or
feedback because you're you're the
master at this kind of stuff so yeah
okay so a couple things to think about
one audience interaction is always the
best you know like most people get up
there and just speak and speak and speak
and speak and it's never as personal as
it could be so as much as possible I
love defaulting to as much q a as
possible but people need to know what to
ask so if I'm coming into room and I've
got 25 minutes to talk or you've got
half an hour to talk I would love to set
the stage with 10 minutes of talking and
presenting something so that people know
kind of who you are and what you're
talking about and then as much time as q
a as possible uh that's my personal
style it's the most fun for me when you
feel like you're actually helping
somebody I think it's also the most
value for the audience too to see you
helping somebody out it's a lot more
dangerous so it's a lot more risky
because you don't know what's going to
come at you and you hope you don't get
asked questions that you don't know how
to answer right you can always say you
don't know there's nothing wrong with
saying hey I don't know right if you
don't know don't fake it and say well
and like some BS answer right
um so that's more personal preference I
used to do all scripted perfect
PowerPoint no time for Q a because I was
I was worried about disappointing the
audience and I would also talk really
fast
um which sometimes ESL uh people
couldn't understand
um and so it's like what's the if you
think about what's the main thing you
want people to get out of this like if
people they're gonna go to a three-day
event you're one speaker out of all of
the speakers that are there they're
going to leave with a notebook full of
ideas and most people are going to do
zero on it this is what happens at
events so
if you were the one guy that they
remembered for one thing that they're
going to take action on what is that
thing I make the whole presentation
about that thing so that they can
hopefully get into action mode
the second thing though like if you want
to get more of this
be the person who brings the most value
to the event so when is your event June
something June 14th June 14th perfect uh
so when shot now I've known Sean for a
long time who organized the event but I
said hey Sean initially is only he was
giving me like 11 minutes or something
it's like cool Sean happy to come on do
whatever but if I'm coming down and I'm
going to be there for three days use me
if you want me to do breakdowns of
people's channels and you want to sell
it as a VIP bonus if you've got people
who've upgraded tickets and you want to
give them extra access I'm happy to do a
special session over lunch if anybody
cancels on the day of I'll come in and
talk on their session if they're hosting
any extra panels and you need an extra
member Count Me In if you want to do
some pre-promotion and talk about it I'm
happy to interview some of the people
who are also going to be speakers at the
event to talk about your thing to give
you content to go from like think about
the person organizing this event and how
you can be as valuable as possible to
them so they have a successful event as
opposed to just thinking about your
30-minute talk on this one day right
um because that way you like the next
time they're running the event who are
they going to call not Ghostbusters
they're calling Andrew Murdoch right
and you just get no 's a person who
brings the most value because most
speakers now it's a virtual event so it
may not be the thing but most speakers
fly in fly out and they don't stick
around where if you're there and you're
asking people's questions and you're
helping and you're the most valuable
person there
um you're gonna get invited to a whole
bunch more stuff as well
um so
you know people who are putting on these
events are under a lot of stress and
pressure and a lot of moving Parts a lot
of chaos and people do cancel last
minute all the time on things and if
you're the guy who is always picking up
the slack
a lot of great things open up to you
um I don't know if you know Jamie do you
know Jamie carlima
no no she wrote a book called believe it
lady Lexi Tanya shaking her heads um
shared a book I believe it became it was
New York Times bestseller uh she's gone
on and done
events with Tony Robbins and Dean and
Brendan and you know part of our crew
and she she started a company called It
Cosmetics and sold it for a billion
three
in cash
so a pretty awesome story like female
badass success story
um and at Brendan's event so Brendan
Bashar was hosting his event and one of
his speakers canceled last minute I
couldn't make it in whatever reason and
so he's asking who who can speak like
who else can come and speak and Jamie
was in the audience and one of the staff
members knew she was there and she said
have Jamie come up she's done some
on-camera stuff and has a great story
and so Jamie came on stage and that
became the birth of a whole
business for her now she's a speaker and
best-selling author although this other
stuff just because she was willing to
say yes so
um a lot of
balls drop on events like this and just
showing that you're willing to to be a
part of it
to you know again hope be on panels
replace somebody if they skip out host
an awards you know if they're giving out
Awards you're happy to host and give out
some of the awards uh bonuses any of the
VIPs who are upgrading part of that
bonus could be I don't know how many
people like it could be one-on-one with
you but that's too many a group session
bonus with you like how can you just
bring incredible value to the people
putting on the events and that opens up
if you if you want to do more speaking
and build more connection that opens up
just a huge world of opportunity
that's fantastic feedback thank you so
much for that and speaking to what you
just said just being willing to say yes
yeah I I didn't uh I didn't hear of this
event before never heard of this event
before they contacted me like a year ago
to uh guest speak on their podcast so I
I did the podcast and then never thought
about it ever again and then randomly
they reached out to me and said hey
Andrew uh we really loved having you on
the podcast we'd like you to apply to be
a speaker at our event submit an
abstract again submitted the abstract
but didn't give it a second thought and
now before I know it now they've they've
got me the second speaker in their their
events and I was like oh and just being
willing to say yes and just take where
the the universe is guiding me I guess
so well and just keep putting out
goodness and bringing value right I mean
today Thursday is our public facing day
for me so it's we started with Brian
Linux this morning and then it's just
all day podcasts and I'm on people's
shows and then this and then more
podcasts and when people ask me at the
end hey where can people find you like
it's always like where can people find
you what's one thing you can do for me
right and if you were if I was on your
show I'd say hey hey Andrew how many
episodes have you created of your show
and you say I know this episode number
84. cool Andrew's done 84 of these
episodes guys if you love Andrew's work
and these episodes and I guess that he
brings on the best thing you can do for
me is go give him some love go to the
YouTube channel give him a thumbs up
give them a comment go to iTunes and
give him a review and give him five
stars because it's so much work to
create this show
that that little bit that you do makes a
means a huge difference to helping that
get up to more people right so I'll use
the time at the end to promote me to
promote you to promote the host and see
like you're the only one whoever does
that right yeah and so then you get you
get asked to be on other people's shows
you get asked to come back you get asked
to speak at events and then you get
asked to get paid to speak at events and
then you get book deals and right all of
this stuff starts to come because you're
always looking at how do I give
incredible value to the person who is
having me on right so you're not just
thinking about showing up for the
30-minute podcast or the 30 minute
interview it's like how do I help this
person grow their business and grow
their brand and be a cattle it's more
it's like for me it's just good karma
like just help it's great
but it also becomes a a killer business
strategy because something will always
come back for you yeah Rising tide yeah
love that man thank you thank you all
right cool samit's got his hand up what
do we got some meat how are you Evan so
good man similar question to Andrew is
actually prior to the invitation
um I made an impact at a live event but
trying to get invited to speak at that
event and uh kind of get access
um in a larger way rather than being a
uh quote attendee where I was I was a
attending a mastermind
um feel that based on feedback had an
impact there now they're doing a a live
event for a larger community and trying
to get invited but wanted to do it in a
way there where I'm adding value to them
but not uh coming off as desperate or
yeah okay so two things one is in the
and the lead up to the event is that
it's ongoing it's not just hey I want to
get into this event that this is a
relationship you're trying to build
ongoing so always looking for new ways
to help them think of them I have a list
of people that I want to stay in touch
with and at least every 90 days I have
to do something to stay in touch with
them somehow right so put this person on
your list find a way to at least every
month think of some way to add value so
that when a next event comes up you're
automatically the person that people are
calling like I'm getting destroyed right
now with a number of invites to things
because over the past two years all I've
done has been helping people grow their
thing and now that events are coming
back and the World's opening up if
you're like hey Evan can you come speak
at this Heaven Can you like
now it means a great problem to have but
it's because of two years of just
bringing incredible value to people so
think of it long term as well so every
30 days you're doing something to bring
value to them second thing is you reach
out like now you've got this event
coming up you reach out and thank you
when you say add value what does that
mean to you like what like that example
of what you shared uh when it comes to
speaking and event and standing out and
doing more than others like I wrote down
those like whatever it is in terms of a
value-op after that you're adding
additional when you say add value I feel
like you know sometimes it's harder to
break that down of what is actually
meant add value to you so that's
different for every person right so so
what value is for me is different than
what's value for Sergio and Maria right
so uh I have a thing called be their
chief goal officer like whatever their
goal is becomes my goal so if Andrew is
going on to speak at this person's stage
what's their goal their goal is to have
a great event so angel can do more than
just give a kick-ass three-minute speech
he can help the entire event be better
and offer the sub in right that's
useless to somebody who's not hosting an
event
so the people who you're trying to
connect with what is value to them the
value that I can bring Brendan Bouchard
is different than the value that I can
bring Peter on right it's just
everybody's valuing different things so
that's your job is be their chief goal
officer and here's what's important
either you can do the work yourself or
you can make a connection to somebody
who can like a lot of times what they
need help with isn't something that you
can actually do but you can hustle to
find the person who can help them do
that thing and you're you're the guy who
made the connection happen so we often
default to say well I don't know how to
do that but you don't necessarily have
to know how to do that you can just try
to find the person who can help them do
that and a quick tell is look at their
Instagram bio look at their Twitter bio
what are they promoting what's in their
link that's what they care about the
most right now help them get more of
that thing
it's interesting very helpful thank you
um uh the other part is like okay well
that's how to build ongoing
relationships it's what do I do right
now because there's an event coming up
like when is that event coming up I
think it's uh third week of June yeah
all these June events 11. uh you reach
out and say hey I'd love to come and
speak on x
and I I just did this with Alex who's
who helps me run trying to dance salsa
Alex is going there's an event in
Toronto right now for entrepreneurs uh
Archangel something happening
um and Alex's was gonna go as a guest
like you can't just go as a guest dude
that's not enough like you you need to
go and you should be on stage doing
stuff and like well but I don't have you
know people don't know me as a speaker I
don't have a story to share it's like
well and he's already got his lineup
book it's like okay cool well you're
what's your business he has dance
classes right he teaches people how to
do salsa bachata dancing like so what
does an event need event needs people to
Hype them up with dance you go to Tony
Robbins event before you get on you see
people dancing going crazy reach out to
him and say hey I'd love to Hype up the
crowd before you come on and teach them
some salsa dancing and get them going so
they're not in their seats
right and he said yes
so now two days in a row it was
yesterday and today this is very meta
it's like happening right now Alex wakes
up at like 5 30 in the morning gets
downtown Toronto to go to this event and
he's hyping up people and teaching him
how to dance before the next speaker
comes on this was not something that was
initially planned in his event
but it brought value to the person and
sure maybe maybe seat will come when
they sign up for classes but the point
isn't to sign up for dance classes we're
not selling anything there the point is
to build a relationship with the people
who are putting on the event so that now
any future event guess what they're
going to call Alex and have him be the
hype man at the front teaching people
how to dance
right that's that's super helpful and
one other thing I don't know if you've
ever enjoyed this but oftentimes it is
someone throwing the event might have
their business in one core area and if
you compete they're really trying to
build refer audiences but not a
competitor
does that make sense yeah but it's like
Chief gold officer like what are they
trying to what do they want to build
yeah and you help them you help them try
to build it if they're trying to build a
referral business help them get more
referrals if they're trying to build a
direct sales model help them get more
sales if you're trying to have a great
experience like and and sometimes you
have to guess
like everything I suggested for Andrew
is a guess
I don't know who I don't know the event
I don't know who who those people are I
haven't looked at their buy I haven't
looked at their website but haven't done
enough events
those things usually come up speakers
cancel there's bonus upgrades right like
there's opportunities like the thing
with Sean now turned into a 25 minute
thing that was supposed to be for 11
minutes and that's it before Gary right
now it's 25 minutes plus I'm gonna be uh
doing two other things with them there
plus we just did a live stream on this
channel two days ago talking about it
and so now I'm hyper involved in it just
because I want to be because I hate
going to an event and just sitting there
in the audience I like to be involved in
the thing but
you can take a guess at what they're
doing and the more that they're actually
sharing especially again like the hack
is to look at their their Instagram bio
Twitter bio see what they're promoting
but if you know that hey they're trying
to build a referral engine cool that's
like the greatest thing you can they can
tell you help them go build a referral
engine either you or make introduction
to them that can help I appreciate it
thank you Evan yeah cool and just one
last Quick thought on on all of this
because this all seems to be around like
networking Making Connections helping
people
um
Charisma on command I don't know if you
ever if you know their YouTube channel
but they made a uh they made a video on
me saying I was one of the greatest
networkers that he had met
like the guy who makes like the Charisma
Channel saying I'm like the greatest
networker that he's met it's crazy
because I don't think of myself as a
networker I hate networking events this
is the worst thing of all time for me
networking are you kidding me I don't
say hi to people I hate it but all I
basically was doing is he broke down
this video was I was just being people's
chief goal officer so one of the things
I did was when somebody somebody came
and talked to me and I always being an
introvert I'm curious so I listen and so
I asked what are you doing like why are
you here what are you what are you
trying to learn and one person said that
he was doing an interview series on
entrepreneurs I think it was one Sean
was there interviewing entrepreneurs he
was like hey I'm trying to get
interviews lined up from my YouTube
channel at the time it was uh it wasn't
his think channel was uh video
influencers I think was the name of the
channel
I'm trying to line up people for this
for my channel so cool so like chief
goal officer Sean's here because he
wants interviews for his channel right
so now anytime somebody's telling me
about their Channel I introduced him to
a bunch of people and other people just
based off knowing what they want it's
like hey do you know him oh hey do you
know him just people who came up to me
and started talking I learned about what
they wanted and connecting people
together all of a sudden I'm this genius
networker
like why are you kidding me I'm just
trying to help you guys right but I
didn't do anything I just introduced two
people together who didn't know each
other because I thought there might be
you know a common interest or need and
then you get you get people calling you
you get people wanting you to help them
with other things and be involved in
their product Services events Etc so you
know value is different to different
people be their chief goal officer
understand what they want and help them
get it I think it was Zig Ziglar it's
like you can have anything you want if
you help other people get what they want
something like a Zane probably you know
Zane what's a quote that's it you got it
just like be the chief goal officer more
than what you're hired to do the advice
for Andrew is like don't just go and
give a kick-ass tweet you could be the
most memorable speaker there awesome
that's great value and like plus how
else can we give value to these guys so
that their whole event is amazing not
just your individual speech right if you
can start thinking on that level just it
feels great you know but also amazing
things open up to you
the theme today was how to network and
connect to a mentor networking quickly
in in 2022 I think the easiest way to do
it is actually through content if
there's somebody that you want to to
connect with I think content is the
easiest way to do it where people will
come to be on your show where they
otherwise wouldn't
talk to you
like you can slowly work your way up and
build a network and get known uh and ask
friends and and work your way through
Linkedin or wherever they get to the
person but I think the show is the
easiest way to do it uh what I would do
is think about who do you want to talk
to
uh who do you want who do you want to be
your mentor
and then look at who they are following
on Instagram
and then go and try to get those people
on your show
and then you can reach out to that
person and say I just had this person
and this person on my show I'd love to
have you on too because everybody who
you look up to they're following people
who are not huge names
right so you know I'm I'm I'm I don't
know who I'm following I'm following
Tony Robbins uh I'm probably following
the rock you know don't don't go and try
to get the rock Chris is very happy
about that don't go try to get the rock
to get to Evan Carmichael it's probably
the other way around I don't know if you
know who I am so forget about that but
I'm following I'm following other people
right
um like if you if you messaged me and
said hey Evan I've started a new podcast
I've had uh my previous guest Mark
Elwood Evan tinsman Zan the man and
Andrew Murdoch on my channel it's like
oh those are four pretty awesome people
I know all of them I'm immediately more
likely to want to say yes to you because
you've had some of my friends on
and you can find people who are going to
be
easier to get access to right so if you
if you messaged Zan and said hey Zen I'm
starting a new show I'd love to have you
on my podcast would you say would you
come on Dancing be like heck yeah I'm
down right boom and anybody who follows
including me is now more likely to say
yes because Zane's been on so that
that's what I would do like whoever you
want to be your Mentor look at who they
are following not who follows them but
who are they following and try to get as
many of those people on your show as
possible and then when you have the
person on your show don't turn it into a
show where you're asking boring
questions that you think the audience
cares about turn it into a mentoring
session
we have the mind you say hey I'm I'm
struggling with X what what should I do
and that becomes a show or I think for
most people they're doing they're asking
the questions they think Their audience
cares about and it ends up being a lot
less effective it's today's my public
facing days it's all day interviews and
it's like I just came from one going to
the one after this so it's hectic energy
but I can't tell you who often happens
that we asked the person asked me we
spend 25 minutes together
they ask me all the same questions that
everybody else asked me they use the
insane intro that everybody else uses
and then thank you so much Evan you know
final words great where can people find
you awesome close the show it's like hey
Evan I got one last question you know
that's for me on uh how do I it's like
that should have been what you led with
like we could have talked about that for
25 minutes instead of the boring stuff
you asked me no I don't say that in as a
blunt a term most of the time but but
that concept is like whatever you really
if you're having somebody on
you really want to get a specific
message out of them for you what is that
because chances are your audience will
care about it as well and if you don't
have a show then you start a show around
it
I think it's the easiest way to get a
hold of anybody's attention in 2022
that's what I would that's what I am
doing it's what I would do I have Tony
Robbins coming up
um next week I'm doing an interview with
him it's the third time he's been on the
channel and I don't you know I I know
Tony but I don't know like I can't text
Tone and say Tony I'm really struggling
with this thing can you help me right I
don't know him fortunately a bunch of
people I do know that well now but I
don't know Tony that well right so he's
got a new book out called lifespan
talking about extending human life so
I'm gonna I'm not gonna ask him the
usual Tony why did you write this book
Tony what are you most proud of from
this book Tony why now on this book like
if I ask them those three questions
that's what everybody's asking him and
then my 25 minutes is done because he's
gonna go on his amazing answers but the
same answers you get to everybody else
so I'm going to ask him hey Tony here's
what I'm struggling with
what do you think about this
and so questions that I actually deeply
care about
and so I'm getting mentored by Tony
Robbins
um anyway so that's my my hot take
networking in 2022 Let's uh let's let's
turn it over to you guys I see Lydia's
got her hand up so what do we got Lydia
good morning I've got two questions
um I watched a video you did with Pablo
um the other day and and I believe Jen
had mentioned this earlier about uh your
name uh your channel your name and your
channel and you're the brand and so
um
I'm needing to flip
into that place because my brand was not
my name and it it has been
um my my Persona right so I'm trying to
flip it and I want to know
um right now it's Common Sense Mamita
and I am and and so in watching your
video I'm thinking okay maybe it's Lydia
Nicole's common Lydia Nicole is common
sense Mamita or is it Lydia Nicole and
then
everything that I I have like close to
700 videos with common sense of Amita on
it I'm just trying to figure out how to
bridge that right now
so I I honestly wouldn't overthink it
the way that I would process that is
imagine you so now you're you know 20
years later we're in 2042
are you still the common sense Mamita
yes I'm always going to be the common
sense Mommy that because I think I have
common sense
but are you always going to be a Mamita
is that is that always like gonna
resonate with you yes I think then keep
it then it's fine then you are you build
the brain as the common sense Mamita I
think the problem is
for a lot of people's like oh no I don't
know if I want to stick with it for that
long and then it's easier to build a
personal brand off your name because you
can you can switch it to whatever you
want it to be because I'm always an
evolution of Evan Carmichael okay so
then my next question is is the part two
of this
um I've been noticing on your channel
and other other big
um YouTubers they they will have
channels within their channel
right so you you like you have your best
of
in Evan Carmichael so until you get to
daily content I wouldn't worry about
splitting up channels
or if it's just a totally different
audience well what I'm thinking of
because I also do prayers
and um I've lost a couple of people in
doing the prayers
and I am wondering if I just slide it
into another Channel
if it's a different enough audience then
yes but usually the answer is keep it on
the same thing because at the end of the
day
the people who are watching Common Sense
Mamita what do you want them to feel at
the end of watch one of your videos
I want them invigorated I want them
encouraged and I want them motivated to
do something what an answer I love it
let's go okay great
when somebody is finished watching a
prayer video how do you want them to
feel
I want them to feel like they can
conquer the world so it's the same thing
yeah so it's the same channel
okay okay I see what you're saying okay
okay yeah if if you are off to go make
you know a Cooking Channel or something
and it's just completely different it's
like I want people to learn how to know
how to cook a quiche because people
don't know how to make quiches and it's
all wrong great that's just totally
different inspiration so that's your job
though is now inside of every video make
people feel encouraged motivated
inspired ready to conquer the world
whether it's a prayer like even if you
go into your prayer with that intention
the prayer will come out differently
even the same words like if you're
repeating Our Father who art in heaven
like
the emotion behind you saying the words
will adjust
with if you're going with the intention
to say I want people to
believe in themselves around people to
love themselves or want people to feel
encouraged and inspired right this can
be a different vibe
um so yeah as long as as long as it's
the same emotion same channel okay thank
you so much cool you got it
so every week we do a poll what do you
guys want to uh want me to talk about
and that's what we dive in soon we'll be
moving over to Discord instead of
Facebook very exciting some of you
already there we got to get there it's
good it's good not just for this group
but good for you to learn because that's
where communities are instead of instead
of Facebook groups but today's topic was
about
grow
your movement using Instagram which is
exciting and that was Maria's question
so why don't we actually why don't we
just pull up Instagram and pull up Maria
and Maria why don't you uh why don't we
why don't we Workshop this since we have
our time together here tell us what
you're doing on Instagram tell us how
what's working what's not and let's Dive
In
all right well thank you again so I'm
really new to you Instagram honestly
um I used to just occasionally put a
little something up there but when I
actually became a movement maker and I
was invited to collaborate with Lady
Lexi I did my first time live with her
and I've been doing yesterday I did it
live with Angela so I've been playing
with it and I realized that I love it I
mean I used to not like Facebook at all
and so I really I'm just like playing
with it I don't really have a clear
Focus although some of the things that
I'm learning with your book and just
really feeling like I have to
um just get a little bit more clear
about letting my followers on Instagram
know more about my who what what you
know why and all of that
so I I've just been playing around so
what you see there is just some stuff
that I've been playing around with this
is great hey it's a great start and
what you said at the beginning was
really important is that hey you did you
did the lives and it was fun
and you want to do more I've done a
bunch of them now and I'm loving it well
well this is a great like hey that's a
good indicator that you're doing the
right thing and you should do more of it
if it's actually fun you know if you
look at your calendar like oh my gosh I
gotta post a stupid Instagram like maybe
you shouldn't be doing that you know if
it's just a business strategy you're
probably going to lose if you can inject
the heart and love into it and enjoyment
you're going to have a lot more success
so this is great
in built to serve we have a section of
the amazing 10 pack of content
that you can use as
as filters for the content that you
should be making really all of the
content is going back to who you used to
be and the audience that you're trying
to serve and especially on smaller
accounts whether this is Instagram
YouTube whatever platform the more
specific you can be to a demographic to
solving a specific problem the easier
it's going to be for you to win and for
you to start getting clients right so
it's one thing to grow a Social account
it's awesome fun but how can we turn it
into a business so the more specific you
can make it the better if you're just
talking about
you know I was helping an entrepreneur
earlier today it was like what do you
want to make a video about well I have
two options one I can I have YouTube
consulting services that I wanna I wanna
sell and I also want to encourage young
entrepreneurs to get going in life right
the young entrepreneurs can get going in
life not even young just entrepreneurs
that get going is is going to be really
difficult and challenging and
competitive because it's going up
against everybody Tony Robbins and me
and garyvee and all of these big players
and it's not that you can't eventually
win but most people quit because they're
not getting the traction soon enough
because you're targeting the same market
and you're not going to be as good as
garyvee or whoever at the beginning
right while you find your footing but as
other target market was going to be
helping people with their YouTube
channel so great go make content
breaking down people's YouTube channels
and show yourself as the expert so uh
who are we trying to help with our like
what who's our client Maria who are we
trying to bring on board my ideal client
a health conscious women who who are
ready to release excess weight without
deprivation they want to make friends
with food heal heal food addictions
emotional eating and have more health
and self-confidence more esteem
and it's already like they're already
health conscious and they know they are
or they're they're frustrated and tired
with their body and their stress and
they did they don't know how to do it
but they want to make a change
no my ideal client actually knows how to
do it they just haven't been able to do
it in a sustainable way they've been on
the dieting treadmill and they gain and
lose the weight and they so they are
health conscious in the sense that
they've made many many attempts but
nothing's been sustainable because I my
my my work is really taking a deeper
dive into addressing the emotional
blocks that keep them from from living a
healthy vibrant body living in a healthy
vibrant body age demo matters or no just
women
uh it doesn't age demo doesn't matter
but typically it is an older woman who's
been around the block a few times with
with dieting and but that starts very
young in our culture so I I work with
a diverse you know many ages I even
occasionally work with men but my ideal
client is is typically
um I love this picture look how happy
you are that's great
thank you and then what coaching what am
I so I have a couple of things I I do I
mean coaching is part of it and I have
also a hybrid program which is audios
videos and um coaching
and then um
and then I also have a um a
do-it-yourself
um you know 24 lessons in in weight loss
that is um so those are the so I have
yeah a couple products but mostly it's
it's the coaching so so then this this
here is great you know do any of these
feel true to you
and and this kind of speaks to a little
more detail of what you just said and
you can I would you know revisit this if
this still is accurate or if there's
anything else you'd want to switch or I
didn't but this is who you're seeing
that you talk to
this has this is the theme and messaging
that needs to be on all of your content
so
um you know I'm I'm I feel disappointed
myself and I've even begun to think that
there is something wrong with me or my
body yes and I make my YouTube videos on
that theme so I have to just bring this
to Instagram now yeah so same thing so
like there's nothing wrong with your
body it could be a a a it could be a
picture it could be a quote it could be
a theme for a live where
um you know we need to do a better job
of putting ourselves higher on our own
to-do list Michelle Obama
that's okay but it's not really that
could be anything it's not really
speaking to your audience
um I don't even care I mean it also is
kind of weird that this is not Michelle
Obama but it's Michelle Obama quote like
like that's a little confusing but but
more you know you your message your
story people will hire you for the theme
that you're putting out not uh like this
is going to be really hard to rank
anything for because Michelle Obama has
her own account and there's lots of
these kind of inspirational
yeah kind of post so in all of these
just thinking about
does my content and this is for any
social Channel but does my content speak
to the audience that I'm really
specifically trying to get at and of
course of course putting yourself higher
on your to-do list
helps as part of the equation
but it feels too General as opposed to
saying something like this where you
know there is nothing wrong with you or
your body
and then telling me about that that's a
great first line of a video too there's
nothing wrong with you or your body I
love it but well it's your words
great a lot of people
my clients all the
old it's operated in my you know your
body wants to be slim naturally
naturally slim and vital the the thing
is that there's been a lot of static
between the truth of who you are and
that shows up in all the diet mentality
and yeah that's another great opener
right your body wants to be naturally
slim and vibrant your body naturally
wants to be slim and vibrant like that's
a great a lot of people wouldn't believe
that right like you're crazy Maria
that's not true my body is not wanting
to do that
right so that's a that's a great opening
line of a video that's a great one-liner
on a on a on a picture like this
um so that's that's a great it's just
being more specific
this this will eventually help you once
you're in that bigger category but it's
going to take so long to get there that
if if you made it more specific if you
started generating business from your
Instagram account and your YouTube
account it gives you a lot more momentum
hope courage to keep going on it as
opposed to okay I'm spending all this
time making content and nothing's
popping for me yet yes okay
um so so that's great lives are great if
you love it book more
uh doing collaborations with movement
makers is awesome
I would also have women like any coach
you you have them come on and Coach them
coach women who are struggling with
their with their weight and and they're
going to tell you all of these things I
keep self Maria I keep self-sabotaging
myself with food
I don't know how to get off the roller
coaster
you know I'm fine and then I struggle
and I'm fine then I struggle and and
you're gonna coach them through it and
we all get to witness it live so
go hardcore at your target audience so
you target women help what it doesn't
mean that if a man writes to you you
won't help them but our content is
geared towards women you're saying women
ladies right like that's how we're
leading our con so they know exactly who
it's for I mean even in the brand it's
great like you're using you know the
pink colors and testimonies of of women
who you've helped so sure you might help
men and sure you might help the
occasional
17 year old girl but like we know who
we're talking talking to and that's who
our content has to speak so that I know
oh Maria is for me not General okay
the great thing about going live with
people is that it notifies both of your
audiences so in making your own content
uh it's great to have things like this
okay you're using some hashtags which
can be great to help get some some views
uh we use a tool called flick
so flick
dot Tech that helps with hashtags so it
helps find good hashtags
um what's the pricing on this so seven
day free trial and then you're looking
at
seven pounds a month or 12 pounds a
month or whatever right you pick which
one and it'll give you some suggestions
for your level of account which
um
what hashtags to use
uh it's not it's not like the magic cure
all that oh my gosh because I use this
special hashtag now my account is
blowing up but it's a good it's a good
addition so that when you're doing
you know whatever hashtags you're
putting in
first off you can have more and it also
gives you a better chance like you're
probably not going to rank for Worthy
so it'll give you a better shot at
ranking for different keywords it'll
also show you one of the things I love
is it shows you what you've ranked in
the past on
so if you have been ranking you know for
body confidence or woman empowerment or
something then you can put those into
future pieces of content
and it'll it might spark more like maybe
women empowerment becomes a weekly theme
for your Channel
or body confidence is a weekly theme
based off of what you're able to rank
for so we use flick for that but yeah I
would keep mixing it up so you have your
pictures you have your you have like
these short videos here
that's a very short just a pop-on play
around but yeah yeah it's fine and you
said you are worthy you know this is
great like lady with the powerful
opinion right away and then keep on
doing the lives with people
you know ideally I'd be trying to find
people who are in your demo so
um you scroll down I did a collab with
another health coach where is he which
one was it
um
uh good but not as good as coaching yes
yes because I want to see you doing your
thing
okay yeah so I would I would also try to
Target like if you're doing the collabs
for the movement makers Challenge and
it's you know impact and we still have
you know four days left in the challenge
to finish I would try to Target women as
well who are in your demo so you know
nothing wrong with doing uh uh IG live
with a guy but
the more you can stick to your target
audience yeah that's great the better
it's gonna be great great so those are
some starting points but through all
your content and again hopefully this is
helpful for everybody as we go through
if you can identify this which is great
what your target audience really deeply
cares about what they're struggling with
what their big problems are then all of
your content needs to address one of
these points to make it feel like you're
talking directly to me okay great
hey it's me Sharon hi hey Sharon we see
you I had a question I I'm in the
process of working on my mental health
book and I wanted to know more about
writing my book as I share the
information with my readers
um how does that work where um
as I'm engaging my clients my um I work
in a mental health field
um I work in a hospital yeah I am I'm a
behavioral health Tech so I I teach
coping skills in the hospital and um a
lot of the teenagers had shared with me
that they feel like a burden to their
families they feel depressed and
suicidal
um and they they are struggling they
don't have friends their grades are bad
and so I thought about when how I felt
when I was 13 14 15 years old and it
turns out with reading your book I was
able to find my pain
and um what did you put on the book
oh it's like stickers
that's amazing it's like a superhero
girl sticker is that what is that it's
hard to kind of see
yeah it's a superhero girl sticker yeah
some stickers yeah I like it well if you
see Zayn's copy it's all falling apart
and pages are all over the floor all the
times
with with uh with the copies anyway cool
so so it was a question around like
writing the book marketing the book what
do you need help with yeah so I want to
be able to engage my clients so that
while I'm writing my book they can um
give input and I can have my book paid
for as I'm sending it off to the
publisher office I forget how he's
called but it's a technique that you
guys call
um
um the book is paid for as you're
finishing writing it what is that
technique called well you get pre-sales
yeah yeah okay so is there a video
teaching that do you have a video on
that or something I want to know how
that looks like you're not writing it as
you're on video with the right or like
what's that Series so I've done a couple
of videos individual videos on books as
well as like my biggest lessons the
things that I would do again the five
things that I made a mistake on there's
a bunch of those videos on the channel
um the other thing that might be helpful
is what I was writing my first book I
didn't do it for Bill to serve but my
first book your one word I did a weekly
video on me writing the book and what I
would do is update people every week
where I'm at what I'm doing any
challenges I'm facing and then I would
answer people's questions from the last
video and I did that for I don't know I
probably did about 30 videos in that
Series so that might be helpful for you
two things to think about one for people
writing the book
if you're writing non-fiction like
you're going to write an advice based
book understand that the the content in
the book is basically a coaching session
that's one way
okay so when you're sitting there and
you're talking to the youth and they're
suicidal and they've got all these
issues you're listening and you're given
advice and then you're seeing what
resonates and then you're listening some
more and then you're giving some more
advice
when you're doing a book you can't
listen
right one-way communication they're only
listening to you so the best books are a
result of you and also you know Maria
and her videos any anywhere where it's
one-way communication
the best ones are you've done the
coaching so much that you know what the
reaction is going to be
and you can anticipate the resistance
because with any good coaching you're
going to get resistance they're going to
say yeah but it won't work for me
because of this and then you have to you
have to address those things if Maria is
talking tapping people might say tap
that's stupid tapping doesn't work I'm
gonna I'm gonna touch my head three
times and now I'm gonna lose my weight
right like she has to address those
things in the videos where people won't
they badly need the help but they won't
do it because they don't they don't
trust the process so if you've done it
enough times if you've coached enough
people then you know what the
resistances are and that's what needs to
be addressed in the book as well as the
the advice of what to do so a great way
to do it if you're still going through
the process is you can coach people and
have them be different chapters in the
book you can have somebody who you're
helping
one of the youth that you're you're
working with and different issues that
they bring up you have somebody be a
sample so somebody's suicidal then you
actually take somebody who is suicidal
who you've helped and you you you coach
them and their and their story is told
in the book now maybe they're okay with
them being their names maybe use a
pseudo name maybe you change the gender
change the city you know like a lot of
that stuff doesn't really matter some of
the stuff we built to serve the real
stories but I've changed some of the
people's names or where they're from who
didn't want to be identified and others
who are very much identified because
they want to be in the book
um so that's one it's like you can use
people with their permission as stories
to share so it's not just advice but
it's hey here's how this person didn't
the stories always do super well on the
marketing side it's taking people along
the journey one of the biggest mistakes
that authors make is oh my gosh it's so
hard to write a book
but the harder part is actually
marketing the book after it's written
it's like well what do I do and they
wait until the book is done before they
do any marketing bless you Maria uh and
so the answer is while you're still
writing you're documenting the process
of you writing the book and you start
sharing the messages around it so
um whether it's YouTube or Twitter
Instagram Tick Tock whatever platform
you feel most comfortable on you start
sharing the Journey of you writing the
book it's okay today I'm writing this
section the book and I'm going to do it
by interviewing somebody who I helped
through this process
and some of them might be good wins and
some of the videos if you go back and
watch my year one word videos some of
them were frustrating it's like my
publisher gave me this cover and I hate
the cover and and we don't have time to
fix the cover and do something else like
you're showing the downsides or the
negative Parts as well the ups and downs
of you actually building this so it
gives you a reason to talk about the
book every week and put on people's
radar without talking about the book and
just saying hey go buy my book so both
like you use the people and their
stories to make the book actually better
and then every week you're sharing the
journey the pro you can even use this
like hey so this week I went on Evan
Carmichael's insiders group and I asked
him about how to Market my book because
I want to make sure it gets into as many
people's hands as possible right so
whatever you're actually doing to launch
and promote the book you start telling
people the behind the scenes of it so
it's another chance to teach them but
also talk about the book
mmm I like that I think I appreciate not
um I have I have a co-worker who has um
two teenagers and she's been putting it
off this came up that came up I want to
use them as practice for you know so
they can share testimony and so do you
think it might be fine for me to just
ask co-workers or because some of the
kids we service in the hospital you know
I'm not there I'm not I'm not allowed to
just be with one-on-one coaching because
I have to serve a group of teenagers and
then I'm different units so
um should I so you start putting the
message yeah so if you can't use them
you put the message out far and wide hey
I'm I want to help suicidal kids who
have depression
right bring them to me I want to help
free hop on a call and just guide them
and if that's okay if that's your friend
if that's your sister if that like it
just starts to spread to the people say
hey somebody message me today she's like
hey I'm in Toronto uh my son has ADD I
don't know what to tell him what what
can I do like people message me all the
time with this stuff but if they know
that you're doing this and you're
writing the book and you're coaching and
you might be able to help people start
to refer people to you but you start by
asking so if you know some kids already
you know like daughters or sons of your
friends uh-huh awesome for practice yeah
okay yeah cool thank you so much I
appreciate it all right good luck
welcome welcome uh great to have you
Sharon
this week was about YouTube so Maria I
was asking about YouTube tips uh since
it's a nice intimate group Maria do you
wanna do you want to unmike and tell us
about what you're working on and how I
can help with YouTube thank you Evan I
know that you have a lot of
information on YouTube and I'm pretty
new to movement makers so I've been
going through the training materials and
and this year my focus is to is to clean
up my YouTube channel to optimize it to
make better videos I'm really motivated
and focused to to grow my audience in
that way but I just thought that I know
that you have a lot of information out
there but any thing off the top of your
head or tips about
um like I'm going through with some of
the things I've learned from your
trainings about changing some of my
thumbnails and my titles and then also I
have to you know I'm really learning how
to make better videos like engaging at
the very beginning and and and so the
more I do that so right now I'm
committed to making a new video once a
week
um I'm thinking even more than that once
I get really back on track with feeling
better yeah
um but um yeah this is my goal this year
that's really how I I found you and
decided to jump into movement makers is
I was looking for some guidance in in
that area
cool well welcome to Movie Makers great
to have you there too let me just load
up your YouTube and for anybody who's
thinking YouTube
2022 are you nervous Maria are you
nervous well I feel a little embarrassed
look at all these people who are all
gonna
leather isn't that amazing let's give
her some claps
there you go Maria
this is all it's all it's all fun so
this is you right this is me yes this is
the channel body confidence Solutions
with Maria correct all right cool so
this is a channel so
uh it's great that you have you know a
banner and you've got your thumbnail
here it's great that it matches it could
be obviously wider so that it it fills
up more of the space but it's a good
start you're linking off to
a lead magnet yeah a book three
essential steps to step emotional eating
got it so I would probably do a picture
of the book because when I land on this
page this is great it says ebook stop
emotional eating and then I land here
and I see health conscious women okay
like show me the book okay it'd be great
to see the book it's great that you're
doing this that you have a a landing
page you can start to get business from
it but a little more obvious so I don't
know I guess it says it here yeah but
but you're forcing the women to come and
do more work as opposed to
but yeah like where's the cover show me
the cover of
the ebook so I know I'm getting an ebook
great but but this is great
um content looks like you've been making
two days ago five days ago two days ago
three weeks ago so we're getting there
we're making our content I like it you
is it is it through tapping or are you
doing coaching too or what are you doing
so I do all of that I'm I'm a I do
tapping I'm a master practitioner but I
also am a food psychology coach and so I
specialize in helping women that are
struggling with usually the deeper
drivers that are having difficulty
aligning their lifestyle with you know
weight loss body confidence food
addictions emotional eating and so I do
a combination of my YouTubes are some
coaching some tapping
um a lot I have a lot of tapping and and
actually
um oh you know I definitely have to go
through these and and actually weed out
ones that are more broader maybe not
specific to my Niche but um and some of
them are not really good at all but I
just want I wouldn't worry about what
I've done in the past just move forward
yes going forward uh you could have more
playlists here so uploads is a great one
I'd have popular uploads as a second one
and then have more playlists underneath
so when people come to your channel they
can see more content so if you go to
mine you see uploads popular uploads
right so that's great that that's your
certain uploads have popular uploads
next and then have different
um playlist so this is interviews that
I've done okay and then shorts and then
my gaming channel and then so you can
have different playlists for different
content that you're putting up so you're
giving people an option to go and click
through and see so if you're doing like
you can have a playlist for tapping you
can have a playlist for coaching
playlist like whatever you want to make
money doing I'd love to see that as an
example here too
and then super quick
um let's let's just load up your recent
video and see what's going on here oh
gosh do you find yourself in a pattern
of releasing excess weight feeling slim
and healthy and then bam before you know
it the weight comes back on again and
there we go how does it feel watching
yourself back Maria well I didn't have
my voice there but yeah it feels a
little weird but yeah I'm I just putting
them up I love it I love it listen it
took me
350 videos until I wasn't completely
embarrassed on my own stuff
um and 700 until I inspired myself so
you're already way ahead of me okay so
what I love this is actually much better
than I expected uh just in that when
most YouTubers are getting started they
the intro is really poor so the only
thing missing from here is just energy
level okay yeah so I actually want to
say that I based on what I learned in
the in your book and in your frame I've
changed my intro the last few videos to
to do more like this and definitely I
realize that's the thing I have to bring
more of my energy to it yeah so for
anybody who's this it's a YouTube
strategy but it's also for all social
content if you if you picked up built to
serve and you've read it it shows the
template for a perfect thought
leadership video and so you're doing
great here that right away you find
yourself in a pattern of releasing
excess weight so you're already the only
thing I would change instead of asking a
question I would make a statement it
okay what do you believe about releasing
excess weight that other people don't
believe and we can role play this and
hopefully everybody benefits from it
what do you actually believe about
losing excess weight that most people
don't believe okay so the thing that
gets me crazy and it's coming to me
right lately is
is a diet it's like we don't need
another diet what we really need is to
to go a little deeper is you know we
have like cereal dieters and and we know
what to do but we're having difficulty
doing it which means we have to take a
different approach because because it's
if if the diet worked then we wouldn't
have this epidemic of people struggling
with food with ways with body image all
of that okay so let's pause there one
the energy level is already much better
you guys you guys hear it alrighty the
thing that makes me crazy and you're
already going the energy is already
better than feeling slim and healthy
right right perfect and this is it's
always easier talking to people than
talking to a camera but this is the
skill set to to develop so that's
already great next use you instead of we
okay not we but you okay you're talking
to the person
and then last is what is the opinion so
you don't need another fad diet what you
need is
what you need to take a different
approach because what is the approach
though what is like what do they need is
to take a deeper dive and look at the
deeper the deeper reasons why you might
be stuck in this self-sabotaging
Behavior because once you start to
uncover that it's going to be so for
instance a lot of people that I work
with they don't feel safe to lose weight
so the best diet in the world is not
going to help them to feel safer in
their bodies like their weight is their
Shield right so if if if you take off
the weight and you don't feel safe you
feel even more vulnerable and less safe
you put it right back on again and
that's up and down right so the approach
is to Inside Out approach to start to
look deeper within and look at some of
the core reasons that you're in this
pattern and it's not because you're bad
or you're not smart enough or you're or
you're not don't have enough willpower
it's because the approach has to be
different the approach that you've been
doing has not been working so the
problem is it's an emotional problem
it's an emotional problem it's actually
a three-fold program a physical
emotional and a spiritual problem I
don't necessarily have to use spiritual
but it's a body-minded spiritual problem
so for instance yesterday I was working
with someone who she's you know she's
I'm coaching her and she's starting to
drop some weight and already she's
snacking every night and we so I didn't
look at so much like let's get more
disciplined and let's get more strong I
asked her how does it how did it feel
the last time you dropped weight and it
didn't feel safe for her so the
opportunity was to start to explore
those times in her life when she didn't
feel safe to be an attractive woman okay
so this is great so here's what here's
what you do and sorry to interrupt but
just like to get it going
you make an individual every video
solves a specific problem you don't need
every video to solve every problem right
so the video doesn't have to talk about
mind bodies every single video talk
about all three things so if you have a
story that you want to share around this
one woman and it's great sharing stories
there this problem is about feeling safe
right so the video is about feeling safe
that's what this one is okay great so so
the the opening though is you don't need
another fad diet to get on and get off
and then feel like a loser again that it
didn't work right the reason why you
haven't lost weight is because you don't
feel safe to do so I love it and I'm
going to show you a technique in this
video of how to release that
perfect that's the first and I'm using
my words and hopefully it's you know
close enough to what you're doing
um
but that's the opening of the video with
that with your energy level just like
you came on and said the thing that
drives me nuts like that kind of energy
level like this matters right this
really really matters uh and so this
video then becomes about feeling safe
and then you share your story about this
person that you've helped and how she
didn't feel safe and she was snacking
she's not snacking because she's a bad
person and she's not stacking because
XYZ reason she's snacking because she
doesn't feel safe and here's how you get
out of it and then whatever your
solution is you you're step one step two
step three right yeah
tapping there tapping to sort of uncover
the yeah the solution It's Your solution
it's great it's not it's but it's not
the lead and and you you need to be
specific around
something that gets you all riled up and
excited okay and don't try to cover
everything
in one video because you're gonna make
another video so don't
maybe this video has nothing to do with
spirituality or
the other pillars that you cover this is
just about feeling safe
okay and then you're making another
video next week so you have another
story to share and talk about
um I would I would love to see you be
able to go more than one a week only for
the reason well two reasons one YouTube
really favors and any platform will
favor more content
and two it's just it's really hard to
get good at something if you're only
doing it once a week okay anything so I
think two a week is good to start or I
mean whatever you can do okay if you're
not consistent at all one a week if
you're at one a week three times a week
if you're out three times a week daily
[Laughter]
and and the better that you the more you
do it the faster it'll it'll come and
the better you'll get just like any
other skill that you pick up and learn
okay great great if you want to get a
copy of build to serve and join us live
for our next training with me to ask
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love